[музика]
біологія біологія наука прожити
а біологи c
біологія біологи
ну-но пізніше я і ти ми малюємо їх на ринок
ще був одразу мило
не шкірні дірки по стику печінка
починається життя
ти вбив bio біологія а дуже багато
інформації ми поглинаємо які нам не
потрібно в принципі але людина вона дуже
сильно залежить від інформації і коли
ось обраний такий спосіб подачі
інформації навчаючі це дуже добре я
завжди це вітаю, бо дітям
це може бути цікаво
тобто вони можуть поглинати не лише
якоїсь там інформації, яка ніяк не
вплине на їхнє життя, а ось з користю
провести час навіть потім телефоном
смартфоном комп'ютером планшетом тому
це завжди класно
[музика]
намагаюся вам алена солянок викладок
біологія школа мої будні і сьогодні
розбираємося служив і вам катанням чому
ж ви на кают онкологічні захворювання
і ще нам сам робот уже традиційний
хіба домашнього завдання по дні
заняття вона за колишнім заняттям
розбирали
ти покритий іменної смерті повям некрозу
chehobo ніби забуте її було чуму на
крос безкиди у вигляді організму а лише
aptos і вид по мало звучать і
доступним чином некроз з рабта! smart і
на передачі на утилізацію інших
продукті вікі відварюється про процес
розпаду кретини
top top c
тидищ і навантаження на організм
оскільки продукти клітини та розпаду
може бути токсичний і ще бату кретин
вийняти ляхум некрозу 1 годину на те можна
вийняти мод інтоксикацію організму та чоловіка
ви на батіг запальний процес цим разом
сам цьому критерію за загибель
некроза на нестандартний шлях і таким чином
чином організм рагуїл і шоу і пензель
критичних ситуаціях є так мало
ніби ж напувати ну і сьогодні ми
розбираємося з харчуванням і ніхто не
онкологічних заварювати ще тут
бувають навчання в загарі через ці причини
кліпи назад на природі живуть ася 100
ват і зла тісна
і начиння і ось і пухлими ми розбирали на
кинув їх за нитками ще кредитний цикл
загориться навіть pump рольова система
токто з але я ніяких вони змії та
всередині шнюк ліпідних і зовнішніх видно
сну плити на якому контролю адже clit інші
цикл відривають його в пивних рамках як шо
вид буваєте
будете збій обидва будете помив кіно на
тему повія то тривалий цикл
заповнюється та плити на травень заглянути та
шляхом запрограмовану смерті з ну
тепер механізм аки за квіти в'януть у
серед них летіли
ось наприклад найважливіша механізм
контролю clit innova у справі з продуктом
авіану p53
zeigen про суть недоглянуті нашої плити
не
і в нормі та його робота зводиться до того
рахунок все у вену продукту ці білки столітті
влада не займається контролем плит
іншого циклу топ тобто shape година clit
іншого у справі відбуваєте окис помивання з
розходження хромосом та затвори ним
ворота надягання спокуси ваніни на 1000
матеріал потягну
продукт лицьового гена
врожаю clit ідуть дефектні letting ван з
коровою tiida на шлях апоптозу
чи ти на травень хвилини
а лише заварюванні такі ви покараєте
природи не так і ви никає означає
ще для того щоб такі види все
мої 100 тис я кисть defect з 53 з
роботу продукті все лагіну
доступно контрольно система ясна в
нашої кляті не
з робота імунної системи топ то
паралельно з механізмом деякі просив я
у середині кретини
паралельно спрацюють e53 у сітка ніною
нашому організму патрулюєте спеціальними
кретином і імунна система яка здати не
до руху палива на фізичний патруль
уітман видання та а побої дно руку він
викидається ведмедик чи ти нам різьблених
конен іван і перевіряють усікли ти або
нашого організму на вигляд по видній свічці
жити лікар на поверх неї шкірну кретину
знаходяться рецептори і чи тинда імунного
стану кірюха ються потяг конини геть
і взаємодій 7 рецепторами та їх рахунку
рецептора вигляд побачите switch топ той
приховані вона лежить у нашого організму
чи ти на імунну систему в вона нині
по youtube ти ну ти знаєш їх шош
рецептори виставляються
inci і свічку живу ціль пароль
молекулярні вині спортивну до чоловіків
і чи так ти на 1 визнаєте чужа і сигнал
для кретини імунні системи на
заміщення таке дефектну кретину топ
там вона і фізичну шукає фізичного
процедури з таким чином проси вич
калітино нашої імунної системи ціни
найкраща
як літинний чи ти не циклі ти на
кілери субпопуляції т-лімфоцитів та
так само просила макрофага
тільки таких критих кілька
і c що означає вся система нашого
організму вона досить суворо
контролюється саме для того, щоб не
допустить і будете їх природи бою ви
будете їх дефектних clit та
або названої вчи на такі зграї
механізми контролю css такі трапляється
так то для того, щоб запустити процес
він до логічного при народженні кліпінг
потрібно ще 1 годину ну адже було seo
мутація в гені p53
top to win з них нормального конів це
свої функції з одного боку as in show
бог розуму і вигляд ніби сербії у роботі
імунної
система таким чином щуп плити нині
російською знав і в перероджень коли ти не
чужу для нас кретину
але відразу милоша для того, щоб така
ситуація здулася а виникли ти жодна
частка душа малоймовірно па-де-кале ти
ну нашому організмі безособових мільярди
алое для tedx клініки та розмножуються
шляхом у справі та у скільки цех поділивши
також бувають і мільярди одну
приватну тоді 1 годину на душі був і яким
кицьки ти наш організм у заходите вуста не
і калитине у справі vsa галина шеклі ти
на wan і видно брехайте досить часто і в
середньому у
за 10 12 роки в клінчі прихований наші
організм повідомляється внести топ то
ми не такі як ми були 10 руки в
тому а 10 років тому москва далласе
чи зовсім зинчик ти тут і через десять
рокер ми будемо і зовсім велику крижану
у прямому сенсі слова скільки кретини
наш організм і буду з міною а лише
оскільки clit інших поділів вид буваєте
був і крапельки
то в районі спамив кита квона мізерна
вона wanna з ну я та зараз він може
будуть аситака ситуація заїкою 1 година
відбувається батька і справжній хаті в
системі та стіл у годині в нашому організмі
пачино я і знову ти аналогічно про
джинна кліпи на топ то вся кліпі на
вона вже неправильно його здати на
дану машину у справі шуму мети
збувається ну по перше для того, щоб
такі поразки редбула вся
вживає на кретину 6 у справі
генна p53 він
у кожного присутній він передається по
внаслідок якого і цих вин я вкажу
якщо ти не вин продаєте усім на хиткому і
як шо вин палома все у якось конкретніше
клятi не організму the same сіетле
ну будуть проблеми з осені ми всі
пляшки
що впливає на його правильну або
неправильну роботу, а ви сама ідея
концерогенні factory в топ так для того
ще в шасі нашому організмі палама ти
грубо котячі потрібно щоб 6 на ньому по
справі та таких причин у канцерогенезі їх
е3 групи фізично хімічним
біологічно струму
надмірного ультрафіолетові ви про мене
не наприклад
прямо вже якщо дружина днк кретини в то
обчислимо можна його вже шкіряний p53
з хімічних чинів співаку хімічні
канцерогени та кіста xxi столітті ми бажаємо
тягарі ж обидва вдихаючи моїх з палітри
вдихання диму які слова і які у
твориться на сліді пізніше про сивим винсом
місця досить почну кільки з
концерогенні archival за ціною безтурботно
для жити про з побудови вдихати це
шматок їж і я вже раз погадала на багатьох
за нитками ситуацію з
бензопірен америці утворюється на сліді
багата разового ви просто не влита по
тривіально на кухні ви можете позиватися
бі синтезу ватою канцерогенний лагодить і в
живота і відвозиш лісову логіку
група канцерогенів цін на прикладі ці
віруси та пиздат його проникати і в середу
але кретини і включати з днк в днк
клітини таким чином сама днк клітини на
господаря може буду вушко джина ці це
шкіру чоловіка з виробництва та по я вас
таких дефектів
ось те, що кажуть що у кожного
людини є ось ракові клітини
це не самі рам ракові клітини, а це
просто у деяких людей через те, що
ослаблений імунітет може цей ген під
дією ось цих канцерогенів та й
всіх навколишніх факторів може він просто
не правильно почати роботу і ти так я
такого щоб ірак вид caitlyn і ціни я
чужі для нас кляті світу за початок
зникли тени
у диких ликах чоловік упав омані
контрольні механізми які контролюєте
і зрозумів і кручений момент у якова на
пачино я робитеся безконтрольного нам
ж зграя записну для нашого організму з
таким чином адже буваєте це як я вже
сказав опис канцероген у peace леді
канцероген у вас серед бувають усі
мутації у самих чи не топ то дефекти
на рівні та контрольний гнів гнів та 53
і далі буває доступна по porsche
якщо ти нам же бутово на топ то
генетичний матеріал у середині c і
clit and even with мінний вигляд
сусідніх кретин дуже часто
по java zloy окисних плити нго на
супроводжуються
помножене на 1000 матеріалах топ нас
є поліплоїдних ти на плани у
плавник чи ти на струм топки плям і
кільки з днк всяких вершин і повернувся на
нормальних
і як тільки такі clit та інші у
творилося вони вже чужі для нашого
організму ж кіль з днк інша
але вже на вигляд повидає ден чи так ти
на господаря це перший момент та інші
надзвичайно важливий момент я раз побачила
на манула муза нитки протягну кретини
взаємодій однорідну коливани заходьте і
маже конини
і за в диких ти нам контактам ванни
bas останнього чого вич в межах яко ікт
кан ин його на із знаходиться його але без
посередника чивают своє clit inout дуже
онкологічні кретини як правило
прориваються таким чином шок люпинів
лікаря я ж трохи сусіди в пору чmo на
тачай а коли ти не контакти
that the clit інесу сиди вже не можете
по дати біохімічний сигнал напишу у
нас знаходиться в кому встиг на мод дуже
грубо до жучок чи ти на пачино я б
чогось ще вона сама
і довгі спека ніяких стрибків для того
щоб по чату раз усюди тасячи
його на пачино я багата кратно робіть
ся
я вже сказав ще там is mine вона кілька
з днк навіть часто у творите і таким чином
пропорції арені в середині циклу ти
давно вже менше вона не така як у
здоровою кретини топ то з нашої
владну плиту подвоїться зовсім чужорідно
для нас популяції калітин і стос porsche
inci там різанини продукти синтезу палац а
подруги ван яновичу взагалі вони перебувають
чи може ти на ось а наша але не наша і
добре почувається сам це кононович
у вас у кліпі ну в середині були до
організму для неї навісною ніяких
стрибків їм вона просто починаючи раз
всюди ось якби раз усюди живіт і
зведені 1000 матеріал з таким чином ви
буваєте владне при народженні ну а
одразу ваще нашому організму з базилією
але через магнітні мішки і в сарай та не
організму і відбувається свій видно
селекція тоді with beer на виживання на
адже на тому етапі cool і вся клятi на
вже забулося, а на тему це пиво
на може бути розміщена система ми нашу
організму біля будинку в папку якушева
виявилося а вона з тику до розумів нашого
організму такі шкіру можна в 20-у
такого папку ми ж на віч у йому
довелося в затоці збулося і
якось їжі на клятi на у творилося початку
розмножив змогла вилікувала і для нас у
золі ніяких на зливки в минуле
імунна система має доступ до цієї
клітці якщо вона себе ось так відчужує
але звичайно wanna травня доступ а справа
справа в тому ще він онкологічних
литвин іван та
дуже часто схоже або їх владні
виду організму частини на рецептори у
на їхні права і не години назми нині
тому якщо ти на імунну систему ванни
обман дружини будівель розписано таку
ситуацію і сам цьому вона оголена можете
на цезар висновок і раз усюди ж не
цих плит і видобувається такому ви
ляльки абакаба імунних критий навіс то
чаєм і кисть імунодефіцитними моєму
прикладі реальна ситуація надіслана
імунітет обидва рецепти розміну не таким
чином шамани просто не розпізнають
сукрити ну і таким чином обожнювання
поділивши на мого на суді за своє вони
приймають вона просто взагалі не приймає
на весну я сама посуду
синів sway me кросфіту твориться у
всієї популяції плям і водна прогнуть
вигляд волю ось із себе і раз усюди в
цій всій середині нашому організму і осі.
скрізь не пухкими і відбувається біля будинку
випад ляльки
у нас йдуть таких мутацій переказ грошей
чи ти нас залишається ще ми на бо за
нормальні тоді носом цьому гонка
логічніше пухкими ванни душу погану
куються медикаментозно у скільки там
зміїний генетичний матеріал на стиль
ще можемо просто настрій 5 їх
дикунських про паратиф збуватися
наївніше рецепторів вона просто не може
ви його пройняті в синок чи тени і
вигнані мужику мигдальний таблетка не
знаю ну не призначено конкретно
можливо так і ось найдай найважливіша
проблема в онкології з роздробленими
таких таргетних чи кивнув називається tor
хоч на терапія у скільки
шкіра наклеєна замінити цим зі своїм
членом виникли і крити жодна мутація
вигляд був ася вінчі та інша цьому зміни в
них red bull і середині серпня рвати на
терапію вона вона прямо на хмарно
снайперски знайте і в раз це найтупіша
ра джону плити ну про тимон і чапай
вчить їх років і немає ісусі нею ціна його
дружини дідька проблеми кузова звариш і
підірвали
медицина в розділі онкології кліп енріке
шанують робить і вся напевно мій етапі
тебе субпопуляції clit енбоно
розростається
кретини пухкими
простягають до собак rowan восени суди
але тут він і виділяють спеціальні рича
війни для того ще тому лева рис
кровоносних судин бікти нею пухкими
оскільки якщо ти на трап оживає і інтер
доступу жирних мовленнєвих і колив і
дотягують до себе симулює рис
кровоносних судин у свій bik геть і
утримувати машину машини запас енергії
їх внесено стрій мої та їх код 1 далі
збувається дуже стрілку і вісь за
міжнародної класифікації стадій
онкологічного переродження та вісь наша
звучно нам system through паршою ступня
інший пройде а 4 та ще іншому вигляд
буваєте
проти для того, щоб установа це
діагноз попрошу раху та гумор cypher ці
чи права ти навіки відчинилася і
скільки їх його на ваших цілей
класифікації нуля до чотирьох
ранжується екшон 0 тонн мах 4 це
була чесна кель кисть на тому це
опікуни 1 на пухлий на розростаються вона
врожаю на еблищі лімфовузли ми знаємо ще
всіх усередині schnitzer допомогою нашого
організму але поросята лімфатичними
вузлами
а в лімфатичних вузлах знаходяться плити
на імунні системи який забарвлення та
взаємодії пухлими і вісь плити на
напав на мій етапі
в процесі свого зростання пачино я ура
стиснуті лімфатичні вузли і таким чином
прав при установці діагнозу раку взагалі
nodus ланцюжок пензля лімфатичні вузли
віці поваги та ура ховайся так вже 3
характеристикам це стаза тоді cool і
пухкі на вже розрослася вона а устілки
ще нове на по pro 6 ська суми ж
неткане на їхні візи чимось чоловіком вона
розрослася і вона застава
його нас давно просто ти абсолютно
вірного назад на простати до сусідніх
тканин і вісь син відрі знаєте добрий
описаний опори на зла кислу
добра киса набрякли на вона може
розвиватися алаєва набу даура живота я
вища
свою тканину але вона не буду я раз усюди
намагайся на сумі ж немає конини своякіс
вона пахла але обидва близькі буду чіп від і
сусідні тканини на півдні сахаліну майре
знаєте куди і просто досить просто
зростання і нам правому етапі cool і пухкі
настою задоволені валиків грубо котячі
шум відкриття пухкими ці з ділянки про
навідуються його не зможе раз усюди
витягнув меч їхнього організму та начиння води
метастази
менших частин нах організму і таким
Таким чином третя характеристика ми-стазіс
моно утворюючи скинеш таких метастази
ось у рилася а я візьму батю машина
porsche та стадії у нас
вище провал пухкий ну лімфовузли і на ура
а не
це 100 землі травня на інші стадії обидва
нас правий на пухкий набил шоу розміру
обидва ура дружини 12 на еблище лімфовузли на
третьої стадії пухкі над волі в
усмішкою велика кільки з лімфовузли врожай
на четвертій стадії ви ликів ляльки на
вали кокіль кисть у народжених лімфовузлів
і
відбуваєте метастази у ре заманити не
внутрішні органи та й одразу дрібниця про
чим раніше ми з вами йому тим більше шансів
буду в завалі промокніть ситуацію теж
ці вечірні пухкі ноги у творив і всі
метастази в над ріжки вид мінівен
материнського пухкими
біохімічної with mini цього виходу
потрібні різанини та ліги для там ще
десь на головну ринув для того, щоб
дієти на дочірні пухкий обличчя також
проблем історія ну і в restoration як
зі своїм нічого на роботу тарагон
ВНЗ і новачок вже бензоїн і попрошу
виражаються складаються це органи в мишах
яких розростаються тим екологічніше
пухлими підковані
механічно фізичні набирають за життя струмки
ви на вигляд органів подруга пар ушивається
кола відпочинку скільки пухкі новона
фізичного стрибка Джая
крава постійний до уражених органів
третини крипін і пухкими ванни на перших
етапах ви на руїну ються і виділяєте було
чесно кіль кисть
оксані в продукти розпаду тих кретин
і токсичні для організму та відправила на
тему етапі ми вже знаємо ще мама йому
проблему замку логічну хвороби починаємо
і знаю брід і всі лікарські препарати
для онкології ванни та відправила токсична
для всього організму і тому підведено
інтоксикації інтоксикація кретином та
pajchl інтоксикація лікарським та
препаратами які ми засовуємо осі нею
моторі больовий синдром призначаючи але
сильний стрес і у кінсела нову папку
організмах і там ще обидва види гуляють
ремонтом а як же назад на
якось дезактивації на куб дуже це
псини
оновлюють ці мірки просто фізично на
будівлі виводять ці токсини з організму
то хто б урятував і раніше причини смерті
ось така
не чутно vitol африці чисто рух
імунітету збільшення концерогенних
дій та активація p53 гена щоб він
робив свою так так в абсолютному
провінція наша профілактикою середи наші
ми можемо відродити її владі своїм
організмом і ким чен нам c чи можна
kuwait і тріумфую хірургич на
з 1080 83 мм уроків porsche і була
проведено братію на кишки онуку
тріумфують за допомогу хіміотерапії
про парад та хіміотерапії ось я проблем
іван і відправила на viber кови той хто
он ідею назавжди ти навіки діляться
діляться онкологічні клітини на дощі
особи та здоров'я але ви білкову єдиний
моя промо його терапія також і фокусу
it'sa раз на clit інший пухкими
алла бананами ви berkova висновок якщо ти
на кухні його на будучи потрясу світ не
якщо ти на ios тут би до самого клич
великий розумний кро zukul і плити на
просто фізично ну це його is quite у
mist
виходьте на зоні його на яду ж сильної
інтоксикації організму продуктами
розпаду сім'ї кретини їх необхідна
косить елізу вати а для села в нашій
системи організму води мало просто sova
не нам а таких систем спеціалізованих
виділення великої кількості стивідорних чи
ти
я сама клітина ось це вимерла вона має
ті ж негативні якості як метастаза
яка арт його на березень валового просто
таксі чиї права на не буду робити і взяв
його на вона просто цифра доби син то
якщо кров і буде розносити по
організму буде якесь негативне
вона шила я ніде ми то відразу направ його
ти не будемо вона буду просто токсичною
дієти на різани наші кретини зарості
juice метод фототерапії топ то ви
хрестового все ричу винаякі роблять
кретини
чи ви ми доп романів вигадала
світле подіумі кампус with it in a
secret in the van та будучи у uber кову
дружини знаєш шкіру ось і самий
онкологічних ливарний за 1 7 цей
добре проходить калінічне пробивання по
їжу таких препаратів на ринку на травень
алея препарати йому на терапевтично ми
знаємо ще тут травня ніби ззаду єна
імунна система і зараз на ринку 2011
року я препарат які є собою
спеціалізовані антитіла протикали ти
їм пухлими цінне для всіх ляльки
навпаки і олая такі його але вже я на
ринку на звучали ну дарував і вібрація
таргет на поспішати заросте у чого ми
все святкуємо цей то за 1 асі пор штуки
у сида стеження в голосі онкології он і
напрямок на штуку самого тихого
таргетних препаратів віку будуть ви
білків буває і сам онкологічні
кретини про темні чіп від і здорових
плити та
за 1 17 уроку та генотерапії це підірвали
материнки кого їм цей up to win зводиться
готова ще у пацієнта отримують груди в
кров і сію крові рятують йому не
кретини
лімфоцити вина тисяч на їх modify палити
води фіг у цих таким чином шиття
лімфоцити варто пак агресивними і
віщується їх здати між
розпізнавання онкологічних чи таємниць
чому нарощують усю популяцію
лімфоцитів методом і відкритий інший
культового немає і чому і відправляють
назад до пацієнта та вводять пацієнту та
його власник чи тени олаф ж modify кого
не над з шаблони здати не був іп обороти
хвороба вас 2017 го року
в США ось компанії novartis porsche і
такі препарати на ринок обрала цін
відповідаючи на за розбрат один курс люку
ванка що я
близько 200 5 10 тисяч доларів на одну
люди на вулиці лики роздроблені адресно
персонально для мети довга для Києва
пухлими і такі легіони будуть найменшими
шківи ми для всіх нижчих перебуваємо
організм хто такі за раз стан струмок з
жахливою з онкології
ну і ви були абсолютно праві сюди
профілактики цю ми можемо і тут
таким її здоров'я на моєму він і коти
фактори в рожевих конку логічних пара
радж тут то мама йому розуме ти які
ричу війни які фактори
може внести нас донор мови та в селі q
ну всякому випад як навчальні права
kuwait та
але на жаль підкуповували iv столітті історію таки
масивніше пізніше я за галина розумніша
чим він і думає
ми будемо і думають зовсім так їжу ж
чадний шанс де знати про що шкіра з нас
може захопити
такий самий рак нам заворожує праворуч
там ще виноградини розшифровано і ми
знаємо вже ми знаємо чоловіки з червоними дищами
дізнаємося про різні від дружини geneve якин
еротично може підпадати під мутацію та
створі ось і затримання логічніше
проблеми ми можемо воді знати про працю
так-то ви приходите до клініки за так це
і буде і провини 1000 матеріал допоможе
ніби портного можна буде вона
буквально епітелії так просто щіточку
з внутрішню поверхню щоки
груди і тут гриб виділяє зірки днк і
про знижку днк у нас у всіх плити на хід
на кого не знаєте що
присутні не в нашій днк вид поведінка
алелей які можеш пити за датою
мутацію і створі ось ці проблеми топ то
ми можемо розділити знат і які самі
ти шлюбу намаза врадже
і уколи майкл і ми вже у бізнесі та
проблем цю ми вже знаємо про я до нас
собою по води та регулярний коробник для
групи мови топ то ще ми вже знаємо вуха
мої шанси мати проблеми то періодич
скринінгу ну зараз можуть знати ще
цуценята обов'язково проходять скринінгу
народ у цю коробку молочну залази та
шийки матки топ та це таке раз усюди
ні і зневажають ясна важливий його
регулярно проходять ці обстеження
ідейки inci видаємо до логічних
захоплювати також можна скріні ти і ні
м'ячик від цього моменту таки картини
чому від природи to set up духовністю
перших тец і ситуацію ми попущено божому
червоною ми можемо у but i'll be знань та вид
видно
готує двояких і тут потрібно ще
додати сюди це правильне
харчування та спорт означає
звучали на ослиці показаний про сестру стаки
таке спливаюче організмі знаходяться в
астане стресу товар мови будуть адже
видно ви ще так ну на тему я таку
заняття наша завершена завдання буду
домашні осі таки
подумати і над харчуванням чому ж рак
пов'язані , чи ми з отриманими тканинами
за зустрічаються ті частки вони ж рак
прокладці сковуючі не лають конини
за такі досить складні харчування але я
сп одягаюся ще
викликав 1 це побачимо якщо доступним
чоловікові тебе до і так напевно
людям потрібно розуміти як ми можемо це
запобігти та розуміти що це за
собою тягне щоб намагатися звичайно ж
будувати правильний спосіб життя
тому що я вважаю що правильне
харчування заняття спортом та гарне
настрій це напевно найуспішніші
скажімо так у бійці на цьому фронті
[музика]